[Applause]
[Music]
hello there my visualpolitik friends it
is often said that the national sport in
spain even more than football is
shooting themselves in the foot be that
as it may here on visualpolitik every
time we've talked about spain the
general comment has always been that we
are pretty pessimistic about what is
currently the 14th largest economy on
the planet but hold on a minute there is
also another side of the story that
deserves to be told over the last four
decades spanish society and its economy
have undergone an enormous
transformation since democracy came to
spain in the late 1970s things have
changed a lot the country has modernized
and integrated into the global economy
at full speed rapido some could even say
for example during this time the
employment rate has grown by 15 points
which has meant millions and millions of
new jobs foreign direct investment into
the country relative to gdp has
multiplied by no less than 27 times from
less than two percent of gdp to almost
54 meanwhile spain has also become one
of the countries in the world with the
most investment abroad for years spanish
companies have been investing tens and
tens of billions of dollars all over the
world particularly of course in latin
america
and that's not all trade openness that
is the weight of exports and imports
over gdp is at record levels the ratio
of unemployment to capital has doubled
and the country has built one of the 10
best land ports and air infrastructure
networks in the world in other words
spain is a rich and developed country
that is highly integrated into global
economic flows but we're not just
talking about the economy
over the last few decades the education
of spaniards has also improved both in
quantitative and qualitative terms in
fact although it may seem surprising
according to oecd data since the 1980
the mastery of basic skills such as
reading and mathematics has increased
more than any other european country
except finland
what's more the average life expectancy
is now the third highest in the world
behind only japan and switzerland but
wait there that's about the end of that
story
[Music]
the intention of this video is not to be
an advertisement of the spanish brand or
anything like that on this occasion we
want to investigate the main storms
brewing that threaten the future of the
country threats and challenges so
significant that spain must take action
as soon as possible unless it wants to
suffer an economic tsunami so
visualpolitik fans these are in our
opinion or in the opinion of
visualpolitik the main threats facing
spain and by extension the economy and
the stability of the european union
itself and you know what all of these
threats have one common denominator
[Music]
the burden of age
whether it's due to improvements in
healthcare the mediterranean diet the
beer or the tapas that spaniards love so
much the fact is that spain is the
country with the third highest average
life expectancy in the world which on
one hand is a blessing but on the other
hand could become a major burden
especially when you have the second
lowest fertility rate of all developed
countries
demographic disaster the pandemic has
aggravated in spain the problem of a
population in which there are fewer and
fewer births and of course longer life
expectancy and fewer children that leads
to an aging population in fact with the
exception of the microstates spain is
already in the top 10 countries with the
highest average age we are talking about
just over 43 years old looked at another
way in spain there are 125 people over
the age of 65 for every 100 children
under the age of 16. but none of that is
the worst thing the worst thing is that
the aging of spanish society is going to
accelerate over the next few decades
that means if by the end of the 1990s
people age 65 and over accounted for 13
of the entire population today they
represent almost 20 and by 2050 one in
three spaniards will be in that age
group by that time it is expected the
number of people with working age will
have been reduced by almost four million
people so that spain will have barely
1.7 people of working age for every
person over 65 if not remedied this is
something that could substantially
reduce growth and therefore the
country's entire economic prospects
[Music]
and that is provided that life
expectancy does not increase faster than
expected thanks to new medical and
technological advances if it does the
numbers will be even worse but wait a
minute because potential loss of workers
while significant will be far from the
biggest problem
[Music]
the biggest problem of all has to do
with the enormous bill that having an
aging population entails this is by far
the great challenge the great threat the
great tsunami that spain may face and
that as we've already told you may even
spread to the rest of europe we are
talking about pensions health care and
care services
the court of auditors certifies a new
record deficit in social security
53.16 billion euros
the state spending marks record highs
after assuming the deficit of social
security
the autonomous communities will need 35
billion euros additional until 2030 for
social spending and take note because
these are not paltry amounts think about
it for one moment in just a few years
spain will have on the one hand much
fewer citizens of working age and on the
other hand millions and millions of new
retirees who will be demanding a lot of
public services and benefits how on
earth are the bills going to be paid
what exactly are we talking about and
the most important question of all by
far what can be done about it or is
spain irretrievably doomed check this
out
[Music]
a more and more weighty bill
what generally happens to people when
they pass the age of 65 or 67 most of
them are starting to retire that is they
stop working and start living on their
pensions well in spain the pension
system is eminently public and
pay-as-you-go today's workers pay for
today's pensions with their
contributions pensions whose portion of
public budgets has not stopped growing
to the point that the central state is
essentially becoming the pair of
pensions we are already talking about
one out of every two and a half euros
a quick side note here since 2000 the
cost of pensions has increased by
160 and social security has gone years
without balancing the budget between
2017 and 2020 alone the deficit was more
than 80 billion euros and it's expected
that in 2022 alone it'll exceed 40
billion euros but as we have said the
challenge ahead is even greater
as we've already seen the forecast is
that by 2050 the working age population
will shrink by almost 4 million people
while the number of people over 65 will
increase by at least 6 million all of
them will have higher and higher average
pensions so if the math doesn't quite
add up today you can get an idea of the
challenge the country faces houston we
have a problem but that is not the end
of it
[Music]
the elderly demand not only pensions but
also health resources and spending on
care services for example in spain there
is already a huge network of residential
homes day centres and home services
providing care for more than one million
elderly people even so the percentage of
elderly people with places in
residential homes or with home care
services is still below european
standards which means the public
spending on earthly care in spain is
currently below the eu average so one
plus one is two as there are more and
more elderly people spain will have to
spend more and if on top of that the
demand for services begins to approach
the levels of other european countries
that will mean more spending more of the
time but when i say more i'm talking
about so much more then we have health
spending to give you an idea the average
per capita expenditure of people between
65 and 74 years of age is double the
total average expenditure and if we're
talking all about people over the age of
75 then the cost triples so you can
start to see how healthcare spending is
going to evolve in an increasingly aging
country
pensions care services and healthcare
forecasts suggest that at least the
burden of these three budget items will
increase between 7 and 12 points of gdp
by 2050. and you know what often happens
with official forecasts of public
spending they almost always fall short
we are talking about tens and tens
perhaps hundreds of billions and
increase public spending over the next
few years all of this at a time when the
working age population is shrinking
[Music]
so now you should have a rough idea of
the challenge that spain is facing but
at this point the question we can ask
ourselves is have they passed the point
of no return are you saying grant that
spain is irredeemably condemned to
crisis and economic and social collapse
well yes i'm kidding obviously not in
fact what we're experiencing could be
the moment of opportunity at least in
the search for solutions so
visualpolitik fans let's move on to the
big question what course could spain
take to escape the economic tsunami that
threatens it check this out
sailing in stormy waters
[Music]
let's not fool ourselves there are many
steps that spain will have to take if it
wants to avoid falling flat on its face
under the weight of economic
insufficiency and the first thing to do
if you have fewer and fewer people of
working age and a much larger population
over 65 would be to get workers to
retire later this would reduce pension
expenditure while increasing revenue
wait a minute retire later are we
talking about old people working until
they keel over well yes again no i'm
kidding we're not no
[Music]
when the retirement age of 65 was
established in spain back in 1967 things
were very different people reached that
age in worse condition but of course
since then life expectancy beyond 65 has
doubled from 12 to 24 years despite this
in today's spain the activity rate after
the age of 65 is much lower than the
average for both the european union and
the oecd just by approaching the levels
of countries such as sweden switzerland
or denmark spain could gain more than
one and a half million people in
employment between now and 2050. this
alone would compensate for more than 40
of the expected fall in the working age
population and of course it could be
taken even further
[Music]
the question the big question is how to
do this well in this matter we have a
few examples do not think that we are
the only ones suffering from this
problem countries like sweden japan and
new zealand have been working on this
issue for years
for example in sweden which has the
highest average age exit from the labour
market in the whole european union they
have been working on this almost since
the end of the 1990s over the last
decade they have made early retirement
more difficult they've modified the
pension system which now requires more
years worked and tax incentives have
been introduced such as tax credits on
social contributions of companies that
have employees over 65 years of age and
also on the income tax of those same
elder workers
but perhaps a good example can be found
in what you know as one of
visualpolitik's favorite countries new
zealand so visualpolitik community to
give you an idea in this country 20 of
the population over 65 continues to work
compared to only 5 in the case of spain
and they do it with a higher quality of
life and a personal choice because in
fact in new zealand from the age of 65
onwards you receive the public pension
whether you work or not despite this it
is one of the countries in the world
where the labour participation of people
over 65 years of age is growing the most
[Music]
in addition to the advantage of being
able to freely combine the full public
pension with wages or professional
income there are also other important
incentives
one of those has to do with nothing less
than the system for retaining workers
fifty percent of workers and unemployed
people over the age of 50 receive
vocational training to update and where
necessary retrain this is one of the
highest levels in the world and is
something that allows workers to reach
the age of 65 and a better position to
remain highly
productive in fact the government
stimulates this training with subsidies
and participative financing they see it
as a kind of investment better workers
will mean more public revenue and yes we
are talking about very specialized and
quality training no generic courses
there is a very competitive market of
public and private training centres and
that is not all contractual freedom for
the over 65 allows companies and workers
to negotiate very flexible working
models adapted to each circumstance at
the same time since the late 1990s it
has been forbidden for companies to
discriminate against a worker on the
basis of age or to force him or her to
retire exactly the opposite of what many
collective bargaining agreements do in
spain where labour bargaining is heavily
unionized
[Music]
but getting more people over 65 to
continue working is not the only thing
that can be done
[Music]
promoting saving systems complementary
to the public pension promoting
qualified immigration or trying to take
advantage of the so-called silver
economy are other possibilities that
exist for example spain has a great
climate good beaches and practically
everything retirees demand and want this
means that they could move for example
towards an economy that caters to spain
as a destination for retirees why not
attract millions of retirees from the
rest of europe and make money out of it
well that is precisely what the silver
economy is all about specializing and
turning a challenge into an opportunity
and then of course there is also an
urgent need to increase the labour
insertion and the employment rate of the
working age population and particularly
of younger workers this is a key issue
that we will talk about in a future
video so visualpolitik community spain
faces great challenges in the future
challenges and threats that we need to
start dealing with as soon as possible
otherwise in the coming decades things
might get a little rocky but having
reached this point it's now over to you
how do you think spain should deal with
the challenges ahead what other threats
do you perceive and will it manage to
overcome them leave us your answer in
the comments below and if you found this
video interesting don't forget to like
it so we know and subscribe to
visualpolitik take care
and i'll see you next time
[Music]